bonsoir nous sommes le mercredi 20
janvier merci de nous retrouver pour
cette nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal
votre actualité locale
chaque jour accompagnés de nos invités
mais également des journalistes de la
rédaction comment se suit avec les
titres de cette édition première séance
plénière pour la nouvelle présidente du
conseil régional d'île de france ce
jeudi
valérie pécresse a d'ores et déjà fait
part de ses priorités le pass navigo à
tarif unique sera maintenue mais il
faudra que l'état participe à son
financement le point dans cette édition
et jeudi commence la campagne de
recensement de l'insee plus de 23000
agents dans toute la france vont venir à
votre rencontre
jusqu'au 20 février comment cela se
déroule à quoi servent ces informations
nous le verrons avec notre invité anne
jaubert louiselle chef du service
statistique de l'insee en ile de france
et enfin un nouveau centre commercial va
voir le jour à plaisir open sky c'est le
nom du projet il accueillera 35 magasins
six restaurants et un cinéma d'une
dizaine de salles et aujourd'hui le club
de football amateur yvelinois du fc
mantois 78 rencontres le fc nantes une
équipe qui évolue en ligue 1 pour les
16e de finale de la coupe de france
sur place nous avons au téléphone notre
journaliste sportif est michael et demi
d'euros pour prendre la température mais
qu'elle vous m'entendez oui je le veux
en pleurant alors on est à quelques
minutes du début du match d'aujourd'hui
elle finance viennent d'entrer sur la
pelouse les primes il tentera de
gardiens petit à petit il devrait y
avoir à peu près 5000 personnes dans les
gradins
voilà la température était fraîche
notoire il a regroupé des routes clefs
le terrain est donc très dur
et voilà donc ces conditions climatiques
devrais je pense favori des gens du fc
mantois qui je vous rappelle programme
s'était qualifié brillamment au dernier
tour patins brieuc donc en 3 ème de
finale de la coupe de france
et voilà donc cette qualification et des
pics toriques c'était la première fois
que le club a accueilli stade de la
compétition depuis à 1994
est-ce que vous avez des rencontres et
des supporters michael et que vous
ont-ils dit peut-être à propos
cette rencontre les supporters oui oui
les tubes ardeurs sont très gentils
mondiale il ya beaucoup des chartes aux
couleurs on doit actuellement la dans
les tribunes il y avait quelques
supporters canaris qu'on fait le
déplacement ils sont à peu près une
soixantaine
voilà donc je pense que le le spectacle
devrait être assurée dans les tribunes
et bien michael nous vous souhaitons un
bon match et bien sûr nous reviendrons
sur ce match dont l'émission de demain
avec peut-être une victoire du fc
mantois
et c'est demain jeudi que se tiendra la
première séance plénière du nouveau
conseil régional d'ile-de-france une
séance durant laquelle la nouvelle
majorité va présenter ses nouvelles
actions
ce matin la présidente valérie pécresse
qui vient de démissionner de son mandat
de député est venu défendre ses mesures
wilfrid richier et patrick jacques de
dixmude étaient sur place emploi
transport sécurité à la veille de sa
première séance en tant que présidente
de la région ile de france valérie
pécresse a dévoilé ces mesures
prioritaires ce mercredi généralisation
de la vidéo protection dans les gares
aide au financement dans la réalisation
de nouvelles prisons ou encore création
du conseil stratégique pour
l'attractivité et l'emploi un ordre du
jour chargé attend les élus et les
échanges pourraient être tendues avec
l'opposition autour du financement du
pass navigo à tarif unique impasse à 70
euros pour tous vos lui par l'ancien
président socialiste jean paul huchon et
qui chaque année coûtera 300 millions
d'euros supplémentaires
ces 300 millions personne ne les a et
tout le monde savait que ça coûterait
300 millions d'euros et que c'était un
chèque sans provision j'ai toutes les
notes aujourd'hui des services de la
région qui le disent j'ai les notes du
syndicat des transports et je sais que
la sncf et la ratp
savait elle aussi donc le problème c'est
qu'est ce qu'on fait pour trouver ces
300 millions d'euros
c'est donc vers l'état que se tournent à
présent valérie pécresse mais afin de
déjà dégager entre 40 et 50 millions
d'euros elle annonce la suppression de
la réduction de 75% dans les transports
pour les étrangers en situation
irrégulière on notera également que dès
demain sera lancé une charte pour une
nouvelle éthique politique en ile de
france
ça signifie que par exemple on ne pourra
plus recruter un membre de sa famille au
conseil régional comme ça a été une
pratique assez courante sous la
précédente mandature
sans une délibération express de la
région
qui l'autorisera qu'on ne pourra pas
occuper un logement social régional
comme ça a été le cas pendant la
précédente mandature ni en sollicité
pour ses proches ou sa famille comme ça
a été le cas précédemment
ça veut dire aussi que tous les rapports
qui seront confiés à des experts seront
publiés leurs auteurs et leurs montants
seront connus contrairement à ce qui a
été fait précédemment
enfin changement hautement symbolique le
processus en vue du déménagement du
siège de la région est lancée d'ici 2018
il devrait quitter le 7e arrondissement
pour le val de marne où la seine saint
denis et la sncf a lancé aujourd'hui une
opération de recrutement de proximité un
job dating ouvert à tous où les agents
de la sncf ont reçu les candidats
directement en gare de saint quentin en
yvelines
des candidats qui auront ainsi
l'opportunité de discuter de leur projet
professionnel et des métiers proposés
sur l'année 2016 400 postes sont à
pourvoir en ile de france dont cinq ans
sur les lignes n et u on écoute tout de
suite les précisions recueillies par
william lcd profil
effectivement les personnes qui n'ont
pas de baccalauréat une expérience
significative parfois s'autocensurent
par rapport à un psy de recrutement et
je pense que le fait d'aller au devant
des candidats au devant de nos clients
dans les gars ça permet d'établir cette
relation est de se dire il n'aurait pas
eu l'idée de postuler et là ils se
rendent compte des opportunités qu'on
peut leur proposer
donc il ya vraiment une démarche de
personnalisation de la relation avec le
candidat
pour l'instant on a retenu mon cv je
dois par la suite
avoir un entretien téléphonique si c'est
là est concluant j'aurais jaurès j'aurai
un test à passer dans leurs locaux à la
sncf on est plus à l'aise puisque c'est
ouvert à tout le monde
oui bien qu'il ya des profils différents
et je pense que c'est une première
accroche qui est bonne et transporte
toujours la circulation inter files
consiste à circuler en moto entre les
files de voitures à l'arrêt en roulant à
vitesse réduite cette pratique n'est pas
autorisé par le code de la route mais le
1er février prochain elle sera
expérimentée pour une durée de quatre
ans dans les huit départements les plus
embouteillées de la meito de la
métropole par dont l'île de france sera
bien sûr partie de cette expérimentation
regardez ce reportage signé fanny
bourdillon une pratique interdite mais
pourtant largement répandue la
circulation inter files des motos sera
bientôt expérimenter le but encadrer
cette pratique de sorte que la route
soit plus sûre et moins accidentogène
puisque c'est encadré
officiellement on va pouvoir regarder ce
que ça donne officiellement c'est à dire
voir qu'il ya des accidents voire 40 à 2
par les puits à l'issue de cette période
de décès d'expérimentation les pouvoirs
publics décideront si oui ou non c'est
bien ou pas bien
après quatre ans d'expérimentation les
auto écoles pourraient enseigner cette
pratique à leurs étudiants
mais sous certaines conditions ne pas
dépasser à plus de 50 kilomètres à
l'heure n'utilisez que la voie la plus à
gauche et ne pas dépasser une autre moto
avec une rotation limitée à 30 ans pour
la fédération
on parle de toi chante pour les files de
véhicules
ensuite marc différentiel de 10 20 km
heure cela permet éventuellement avoir
un automobiliste de changer le châssis
plus expérimentées à partir du 1er
février en ile-de-france en gironde dans
le rhône et les bouches du rhône
cette pratique reste interdite partout
ailleurs et je vous disais en titre la
campagne de recensement de l'insee
commence demain s d'euros et se déroule
jusqu'au 20 février dans toute la france
23 mille agents vont venir à votre
rencontre pour collecter ces précieuses
informés
lyon pour nous en parler ce soir en
plateau avec nous à joburg bn bonsoir
vous êtes chef du service statistique de
l'insee en ile de france merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation
alors la campagne commence dès demain
c'est tous les ans pour les communes de
plus de 10 mille habitants et tous les
cinq ans pour les communes de moins de
10000 habitants ces jeunes ne seront pas
si cela il ya un roman qui est fait donc
tous les gens ne sont pas concernés par
cette campagne de recensement non les
communes de moins de 10000 habitants
seraient donc tous les cinq ans mais
chaque commune de moine 10000 sur ces
communes à l'ensemble des personnes est
recensée par contre sur les communes de
plus de 10 mille habitants c'est une
partie simplement de la commune qui est
des habitants de la commune qui sont
recensés 8%
mais pour cent des habitants tirés au
sort opposer ses licences pour les
lorrains qui ne sont peut-être jamais
fait sondés comme mauvaise passe comment
cela se déroule à leurs démons
normalement vous recevez un courrier de
votre commune vous indiquant que l'agent
recenseur va passer vous voir chez vous
l'agent recenseur se présente chez vous
et ce moment là il vous propose de
répondre de la façon la plus simple
possible qui existe depuis l'année
dernière 2 qui a été généralisée l'année
dernière de répondre par internet donc
de l'année dernière mais c'est bien sûr
repris cette année et donc c'est la
façon la plus simple de répondre donc
pour ça et vous prie de vous donne une
notice avec un mot de passe
un code et vous avez vous allez ensuite
sur le site
le recensement et moi.fr et vous accédez
ensuite au site pour répondre par
internet ça dure entre 10 et 20 minutes
pas plus et une fois que c'est terminé
c'est terminé alors après vous avez si
vous n'avez pas de connexion internet
parce que ça arrive aussi de des gens
quand même qu'ils n'ont pas de connexion
internet ou six vous êtes un peu
réticent à un rythme en à répondre par
internet
il ya toujours la formule traditionnelle
du papier donc c'est un questionnaire il
ya deux parties dans le questionnaire
c'est extrêmement rapide via un
questionnaire dit individuel pour
chacune des personnes qui sont dans le
ménage donc un bulletin par personne
recto verso c'est assez simple et puis
une feuille qui concerne le logement
donc avec des questions sur le loge
alors justement quels sont à ces
questions
répondre alors sur un bulletin
individuel ce sont des données
personnelles qui vous sont demandées sur
votre emploi sur votre âge nationalité
sur voila c'est un certain de votre état
matrimonial d'alléger là donc on peut
retrouver quelque chose si vous êtes en
couple par là c'est une feuille recto
verso sur le logement c'est des cadets
des questions cela est caractéristique
de votre logement l'équipement de votre
logement
s'il ya une salle de bains et comment il
est chauffé quelle est sa surface
combien de pièces voilà alors il ya
beaucoup de fins de plus en plus
d'inquiétudes concernant les données à
qui ça appartient à qui et sont elles
données par la cité est ce que on a
droit par exemple de refuser de se faire
recenser de répondre à ces questions
non non non c'est obligatoire le
recensement est une enquête obligatoire
il dépend de la loi de 51 sur la
statistique et toute enquête obligatoire
vous avez obligation d'y répondre donc
vous ne pouvez pas vous déranger au à la
réponse au recensement
d'autant que les informations qui sont
collectés sont anonymisées ensuite ils
sont surtout très utile à la fois pour
les décideurs politiques nationaux mais
aussi et surtout pour votre commune
alors justement comment sont utilisés
sont utilisés ces données après
certaines précisément par la suite
alors elles sont utilisés d'abord pour
savoir le nombre que vous êtes dans une
commune parce que il ya énormément de
textes un peu plus de 300 textes qui
font référence à la population ce qu'on
appelle population légale d'une commune
c'est aussi bien le mode de scrutin de
votre commune que la participation de
l'état au budget ou que la possibilité
d'ouvrir certains commerces ou d'avoir
certaines taxes donc il ya plus de 300
textes et règlements qui font référence
à la population donc déjà faut savoir
combien on est c'est important ensuite
il faut savoir avoir justement avec les
questions qu'il y a dans les dents les
bulletins on a une idée plus précise de
la composition des ménages savoir si on
a plutôt des familles est plutôt des
personnes âgées savoir si c'est des
personnes où elle travaille
quel mode de transport elles utilisent
et tous ces informations là sont
nécessaires et utiles pour le pour le
responsable de la commune ou de
l'agglomération de saint quentin par
exemple pour prendre des décisions sur
les équipements sur les transports ce
genre de choses des informations
précieuses qui peuvent aider justement
après des décisions peut-être même des
lois ou au niveau du budget est ce que
justement ces données statistiques il y
en a donc sur la formation de 50 ans
mais il ya des spécificités qui se
dégage justement alors saint quentin en
68 était une ville nouvelle donc quand
on regarde les les les données sur saint
quentin on voit une ville nouvelle qui
vient un peu moins nouvelle au bout de
40 ans est donc là pour voir l'évolution
de la population qui a augmenté
énormément jusque dans les années 90 qui
continue à augmenter ensuite entre 90 et
2000 et qui depuis 2000 quand on
regardait les cinq dernières années 2007
on voit que la population a tendance à
baisser et quand on regarde à
l'intérieur de cette population la
composition c'est quand même une
population qui reste jeune les tranches
d'âge jusqu'à sa tante en sont quand
même encore très présent mais on voit
que les populations les tranches d'âge
les plus âgés c'est à dire au delà de 60
ans c'est elle qui augmente beaucoup
alors que les tranches d'âge les plus
jeunes on voit entre 2007 et 2012 que ça
se tasse et même que sa baisse sur
certaines tranches d'âge
donc ça c'est une des premières
caractéristiques une autre une autre d
une autre caractéristique qui est qu'on
voit vraiment à saint quentin mais qu'on
voit aussi c'est une donnée qui est un
peu général est que sociologiquement on
on connaît c'est que à travers les les
données du recensement on peut voir
l'évolution de la taille moyenne des
ménages c'est à dire combien de
personnes en moyenne dans un ménage et à
saint quentin on voit qu'on est passé du
début des années soixante dix de 3.5
personnes à 2,5
et donc quand on voit cette évolution
donc cette baisse de la taille moyenne
ou linge et moins de personnes dans les
logements
on peut mettre ça en regard avec l'offre
de logement par exemple sur 50 années on
s'aperçoit que saint quentin qui était
une ville nouvelle où départ avait
construit plutôt des logements pour des
familles et maintenant mais ça manque
peut-être un petit peu c'est à regarder
de plus près mais il faut voir quelle
est l'offre de logement pour des ménages
qui ont dont la taille est plus petit
maintenant alors justement là que m
l'agglomération 50 on avait une grande
île maintenant elle est de 12 communes
mais cela va changer quelque chose pour
votre travail pour le recueillons des
données non parce que l'ours sauf je ne
sais pas s'il ya une décision au niveau
de la commune de réalité de pardon
l'agglomération de réaliser le
recensement au niveau de l'agglomération
mais pour l'instant le l'école et
correspondant de l'insee sonder les
communes donc actuellement on réalise le
recensement avec chacune des communes de
l'agglomération
donc a priori ça ne va pas changer grand
chose ça changera quelque chose
les chiffres bien sûr mais pas dans la
façon de réaliser le recensement est
bien merci à beaucoup à joe berguoises
elle alors voilà n'oubliez pas surtout
il faut privilégier le recensement par
internet c'est plus facile pour vous il
peut tabler chi plus facile pour les
personnes qui se font sondés exactement
merci beaucoup
autre sujet à présent nous vous en
parlions au mois d'octobre la commune de
montigny le bretonneux aura son ehpad
établissement d'hébergement pour
personnes âgées dépendantes au parc du
château de la coudre les travaux ont
débuté il ya une quinzaine de jours
pendant deux mois une partie de la
structure sera déconstruite le chantier
de la résidence services seniors eux
devraient débuter au mois de mai la
livraison est prévue pour fin 2017 et on
prend à présent la direction de plaisir
le projet était dans les cartons depuis
près de dix ans la galerie des saab on
va être totalement rénové sur le projet
baptisé open sky comprendra une
trentaine de boutiques
un nouveau cinéma les détails avec
michael et demi d'euros et florian
lamothe la galerie des sablons situe à
plaisir va subir un lifting de grande
ampleur le permis de construire du
nouveau centre commercial open sky vient
d'être signé l'annoncé a été faite
pendant la cérémonie de voeux du maire
de la commune joséphine coleman ce
berger sa vraie plus parce que c'est une
zone qui est en friche
aujourd'hui et c'est un endroit qui
méritent véritablement qu'on mette en
place quelque chose de qualitatif
le projet comprendra trente deux mille
mètres carrés de commerces 35 magasins
six restaurants et un cinéma d'une
dizaine de salles vont sortir de terre
clairement il y adeux je pense qu'il ya
de la part d'eads et des habitants de
plaisir une certaine demande pour
quelque chose de nouveau
ici à cet endroit qui remplacerait ce
bâtiment qu'il faut bien le dire est
aujourd'hui un très beau ce qui nous
ferait plaisir c'est que quand il le
voit terminer quand ils vont entrer dans
les dix justes
ouah le projet était attendue par les
plaisirs roi depuis une dizaine d'années
avant il y avait un magasin de cuisine
il y avait enfin il y avait tout ça en
fait il y avait beaucoup d'activité et
puis maintenant c'est pourquoi il
faudrait mieux qu'on rénove un peu bas
depuis le temps qu'on l'attend ça va
être un appartement pour les ceux qui
sont déjà là ils en ont marre parce que
les ascenseurs fonctionnent pas les
travaux devraient débuter cette année
pour une livraison prévue avant la fin
2018 le nouveau centre sera présenté aux
plaisirs oit le 18 février prochain
l'espace coluche de plaisir et nous
restons sur le thème de l'économie
les coopératives d'activités dont bois
sont des structures qui s'adresse à des
personnes désireuses de créer leur
entreprise tout en cherchant à tester la
viabilité de leur projet mais aussi de
conserver un statut de salarié ce sont
c'est une attentive au statut d'auto
entrepreneur à la verrière la forge une
coopérative d'entrepreneurs salariés a
vu le jour il ya huit mois et regroupe
déjà une vingtaine de personnes écoutées
juillet mais les nous en dit plus ils
sont est designer restaurateur d'art ou
infirmières tout ce travail dans un
secteur différent mais ont un point
commun
son salarié de la même entreprise
laurent du vignon a monté sa coopérative
d'entrepreneurs salariés il y a huit
mois et compte déjà une vingtaine
d'employés
si on accueille en fait des
entrepreneurs des vrais entrepreneurs
qui viennent développer et pérenniser
une activité commerciale sous le numéro
de siret de la forge sous le nom de la
forge mais y compris être propre marque
avec une autonomie totale en termes de
démarche la force s'occupant de tous les
aspects d'accompagnement stratégique
comptables et administratifs destinés
principalement aux métiers de service et
sarl accueille surtout d'anciens auto
entrepreneurs parmi ses salariés à la
forge d'aller conserver le statut du
régime général nous vous allez de
salariés dont vous allez avoir une fiche
de paye à la fin du mois en fonction de
votre chiffre d'affaires la forge
transformant du chiffre d'affaires en
salaire ensuite les gens qui viennent
chez nous viennent aussi pour contrer un
certain isolement
quand vous avez testé un an l'auto
entrepreneur vous êtes isolé vous n'avez
pas de réseau mais bien quand vous venez
à la forge vous l'avez vu ce matin on
est dans un collectif qui partagent des
idées qui partagent des expériences qui
partagent des galères moi j'ai un coeur
de métier qui maîtrise plutôt très bien
c'est tout ce qui est soins par contre
ma comptabilité gestion fiscalité
marketing commercial et tout ce qu'on me
demande moi je suis une bille c'est pas
mon coeur de métier je ne sais
absolument pas faire et j'ai vraiment
besoin d'un relais pour pouvoir mener
cette activité aujourd'hui l'entreprise
prélève 10% du chiffre d'affaires hors
taxes réalisé par les entrepreneurs sur
l'exercice de l'année 2015 70 mille
euros de chiffre d'affaires ont déjà été
dégagés par les salariés
l'étang de saint quentin en yvelines et
sabords on sont une richesse parfois
insoupçonnées de la faune bien sûr que
les amoureux de la nature peuvent
découvrir lorsque la réserve ouvre ses
portes mais aussi une flore et une
végétation importante deux amoureux de
ce territoire ont décidé d'en sortir un
ouvrage pour nous en parler ce soir en
plateau mélanie faut bien notre joindre
ses spécialistes en environnement
bonsoir melanie south shore floral alors
fait deux auteurs se sont gérard armal
ancien ingénieur agronome du muséum
d'histoire naturelle et johan anglade
gare néo conservatrice de la réserve
naturelle de saint quentin en yvelines
l'ouvragé sort aussi pour les 30 ans de
la réserve naturelle fera de vous le
disiez les tentes 50 ans et c'est à bord
dont une richesse très importante on
écoute les deux auteurs ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que la flore sauvage d'île
de france je lis bien la flore sauvage
c'est à peu près mille six cents espèces
et on en a trouvé
grosso modo 550 sur l'étang de saint
quentin et ses abords ça comprend pas
strictement que les temps mais on prend
les boisements qui le bordent les
prairies etc
donc ça représente un bon tiers de la
flore d'île de france c'est une très
belle diversité parce que 550 espèces
sur 300 la zone d'étude fait à peu près
300 hectares c'est une très très bonne
mais biodiversité pour les réserves
naturelles c'est une nécessité de
publier les données scientifiques qui
sont recueillis et donc on connaît bien
la réserve de saint quentin pour sa
richesse ornithologique mais c'est aussi
une richesse pour la flore et donc on
étudie la flore chaque année et l'était
il ya trois ans en fait on avait le
besoin de faire le point sur toutes les
données qu'on avait recueilli les
données recueillies se retrouve donc
dans un ouvrage que j'ai dans les mains
et qui fait plus de 600 pages plus de
600 pages très fourni beaucoup et le
premier forum il est aussi assez lourd
je la rends là les jo ann anglade
garnier sont remontés jusqu en 1845 ça
représente un travail de trois ans c'est
de la vérification il faut rassembler
les données historiques
il faut aussi faire un inventaire ça
leur a pris deux ans ils ont aussi fait
du terrain puisque sur les trois années
ils ont recensé une centaine de
nouvelles espèces gérard arnal qui est à
l'origine de ce projet nous explique le
contenu de l'ouvragé
d'abord c'est une histoire
environnementale du site alors ça c'est
très très important on a parlé
les gens qui s'intéressent à cette
partie de l'histoire qui émergent qui
m'annonce rappelle l'histoire
environnementale seront certainement
très intéressé ensuite il ya une partie
sur l'histoire de la botanique
proprement dites donc pratiquement
d'année année par année depuis 1845
jusqu'à 2014
ce qu'est ce qui a été trouvé sur le sûr
c'est le bleu bord de cet étang par qui
alors on y retrouve aussi deux
catalogues du recensement comme vous
pouvez le voir ici avec de très belles
photos
c'est même le plus gros morceau de
ouvrage puisque ce sont les 500 espèces
qui sont recensés elles sont classées
par ordre alphabétique elles sont
classées par catégorie pour le lecteur
lambda qui est un peu mon cas c'est
quand même assez compliqué par contre
elles sont accompagnées de très belles
photos et qui nous permettent de
reconnaître les plantes et la végétation
et les auteurs donnent même des petites
astuces pour découvrir pour différencier
deux plantes et s'attarde sur la tige ou
sur la feuille
ça donne des petits indices assez
sympathique on peut partir dans la
réserve
avec tout naturellement ce recensement
aussi un aspect scientifique ça leur a
permis d'avoir un aperçu de l'évolution
de l'étang cette fois c'est joëlle
anglade garni qui nous donne une idée de
cette analyse
d'après l'analyse sur la flore qu'on a
faits dans le livre les milieux à
proximité de l'étang de saint quentin
ont beaucoup évolué puisque en fait on
est on avait un milieu rural on retombe
revient dans les temps du roi et à plus
de 300 ans
donc c'était un milieu rural agricole
semi sauvage et petit à petit la ville
s'est installée et les plus grands
bouleversements on est apparue au milieu
du 20ème siècle les grandes nouvelles ce
les grands bouleversements sont
l'urbanisme mais aussi la seconde guerre
mondiale qui a eu des impacts avec
notamment les bombardements de la gare
de triage de trappes pour ceux qui
souhaiteraient se plonger dans
l'histoire de saint quentin en yvelines
et trouver des astuces
l'ouvragé se trouve à l'île des loisirs
merci beaucoup mélanie je remonte un
petit peu l'ouvragé pour qu'on puisse y
est le voir la 600 pages mais c'est
vraiment très intéressant
une dernière information avant de nous
quitter aujourd'hui une alerte pollution
été lancée dans toute l'ile-de-france
alors sachez que demain l'alerté
maintenue
il faut donc privilégier justement les
transports en commun et également les
deux roues par exemple voilà laisser
votre voiture au garage ce sera mieux
pour vous et également pour la planète
je vous remercie de nous avoir suivis
tout de suite vous avez rendez vous avec
sephora namani pour une nouvelle édition
de kiosques que votre magazine culturel
sur saint quentin en yvelines
elle reviendra notamment sur la
disparition de l'écrivain michel
tournier quant à moi je vous retrouve
demain pour une nouvelle édition du
journal je vous souhaite une excellente
soirée